i really like making uh dirty childish
jokes but sometimes i feel guilty uh
making them all the time so i thought it
would be good to couple them with
something meaningful so i've enlisted a
friend of mine to help out in a segment
we call profound profane with our guest
deepak chopra
can we make it a little more profound
here yeah sure
so we're all interconnected
we are part of a global cosmic
consciousness
we are the eyes of the universe
looking at itself
if i were a woman
whenever i got aroused i'd say high tide
the buddha said
all our suffering
is a result of craving
for permanence
in a world that's inherently impermanent
so sometimes i think about how everyone
throughout all known history has had
diarrhea
jesus had it
buddha buddha got it
uh even michael jordan he still gets it
wow
everybody that's how we're gonna end the
show tonight